esses dia eu parei para prestar atenção
na cor o cara sai da escola ele não quer
mais saber de escola não Só que de vez
em quando bate uma saudade macho da
escola meu m acordava bem cedinho que
estudar de manhã que uma coisa que eu
não entendo é porque é que o que a
pessoa coloca criança para estudar de
manhã botte de noite cab estuda de manhã
perde os desenh tudinho aí a mamãe
acordava dedinho como é que o rico
acorda ela chega Senta do lado bebê tá
na hora de acordar PR ir pra escola ô
mãe tô com tanto sono Ô meu amor então
faz assim enquanto a Mamãe coloca a mesa
pra gente tomar café você dorme mais um
pouquinho tá Já já eu vou PR te acordar
Beijo como é que a mãe do pobre acorda
Bora vamos bora bora bora bora canal pra
escola cam foi assistir filme ontem
porque que é só três vezes que ela diz
vamos embora vamos embora vamos embora
Se não for aí o filho do rico levanta o
que que ele tá pijama pantufa tem que
botar pantufa no pezinho como é que o
pobre dorme ele levanta na hora que o
cabou na camisa tá aqui Joaquim 22 22 a
camisa de um candidato a vereador de
2001 e a cara do hom aqui ó e ele usa
para tudo para dormir para jogar bola
para lavar louça